Here's another example that comes from the World Cup.
I like this visualization in particular because it uses small multiples.
Small multiples take advantage of the same layout and
visual encodings from one slice of the data to the next.
This allows us to make comparisons across the data or
across the different views of the data quickly.
You can find a link to this visualization in the instructor notes.
I'd like you to do the same thing for this graphic as you do with the last one.
I want you to determine how the variables are encoded in the visualization.
The encodings for this graphic are somewhat harder to decipher
because a variable may be encoded in more than one visual encoding.
We've set up the grader to accept a variety of answers, but
when you go to integrate your answer, I only want you to choose
one visual encoding, one of these, for each of the variables.
So what do you think?
How are these variables visually encoded?